ah
at first it's very bright but then as
your eyes adjust to the light you start
to piece together your surroundings the
moving blobs above you you realize our
masked faces and they've got their hands
inside your body okay who'd up you can't
run you can't scream luckily you can't
feel but still you have to watch this is
what if and here's what happens if you
wake up during surgery the odds of you
waking up during surgery are about one
in nineteen thousand that may not sound
like a lot but considering the doctors
perform over 130,000 inpatient surgeries
daily in the US alone it's close to
seven people every day when it does
happen it's usually painless and you're
usually back under in about five minutes
but that's not to say there haven't been
some horror stories in a study of people
who've experienced anesthesia awareness
18% reported feeling pain and some even
developed post-traumatic symptoms like
increased stress nightmares and
flashbacks so how can a routine
operation go so terribly wrong and what
happens when it does before any surgery
an anesthesiologist will review your
medical history and ask you about your
habits and your lifestyle everyone
reacts differently to anaesthetic so
it's the anesthesiologists job to figure
out a dose that will keep you
unconscious during surgery without
inhibiting any of your critical life
functions as you're counting down
getting heavier getting sleepier getting
up what is it morning already
[Music]
anesthesia alertness can play out in
different ways it usually involves
complications with the sedative the
paralytic or both if the paralytic wears
off but the sedative doesn't you'll
remain unconscious but your body might
still move and II statists are normally
quick to pick up on this and will
immediately fix the problem by adding
more paralytic agent then there's the
problem of both the sedative and the
paralytic wearing off this is also easy
to catch because the patient might try
to speak or sit up but again doctors
will have you back under in less than
five minutes perhaps the most dramatic
outcome is if the sedative wears off but
the paralytic doesn't in this scenario
you can wake up during surgery and you
might even feel it but with the
paralytic agent working as it's supposed
to you can't communicate that you're
awake while that scenario is
particularly rare it's happened enough
times to inspire one too many movie
ideas but if you're scared it could
happen to you there are ways to further
reduce your risk of anesthesia alertness
it's always important to have up-to-date
medical records and to follow your
doctor's instructions carefully before
surgery so bonus points you can cut back
on alcohol and tobacco
since heavy drinking and smoking can
affect how your body responds to
anesthetic drugs as long as you keep
making healthy choices and don't let the
movies scare you too much then your next
surgery should go smoothly when you wake
up at the right time you can thank your
doctor and in your downtime you could
thank what if